Speaker 1: All right.
We're going to look at what many of you wrote
in over the last week.
We're going to start with something that.
Is scary too much.
Is it too much to call this scary?
This is where we are right now.
Ray Wright commented on YouTube.
I, as well as every other MAGA fan, will never
vote for anyone else but for the true president
Donald Trump.
He could be behind bars and we will still
vote for him.
Trump is the only one that we can trust right
now.
This is a call.
We know that this is a cult.
We've spoken to cult experts.
We've spoken to conspiracy experts.
We've spoken about brainwashing.
We say every expert looks this up and down
and says, yes, this is a cult.
But we also have to deal with the political
reality on the ground.
And so when we see, oh, Tim Scott announced
that he's running, Tim Scott is somehow going
to win a Republican primary over Trump.
Give me a break.
Ron DeSantis is trying to be like Trump but
be different than Trump.
One aspect of why these guys don't really
have a shot is because of them.
The other aspect of why they don't have a
shot is because of people like Ray Wright.
Trump has assembled a cult of personality
around him that is unlike.
Listen.
I never like to say it.
We've never seen it in history.
No.
There are overt cult leaders and they have
cult followers.
That's not new.
But in the modern American political era.
There has never been a cult around an elected
official in the United States the way we see
around Donald Trump.
So when Ray Wright says this stuff, the true
president is Trump.
He could be behind bars and I'll vote for
him.
Believe them because they're telling us the
truth.
And the question for us is, how do we ensure
that Trump doesn't get another four years?
The answer is quite simple, but making it
happen is another question.
Let's look at some other messages that came
in the tin guns, Smith said.
Oh, boy.
On YouTube.
Don't ban books in schools except for heavy
violence or sexual items like genderqueer,
for example.
Now, every time I see stuff like this, I'm
of two minds.
On the one hand.
The Bible has to be banned based on this,
Right?
I mean, there's no way to follow this guideline.
Heavy violence and sexual items.
You must ban the Bible from school if you
actually are going to be serious about that.
But then I'm also reminded that when you look
at what materials have been banned from schools,
it's often just a completely unremarkable
novel.
The coming to age novel where the main character
or the author happened to be LGBT ban it.
And so, yes, they're hypocrites because the
Bible is fine, but also their standards are
extraordinarily pathetic, and it shows such
a lack of tolerance for anything other than
what they I guess now pretend school kids
need, which is stories by heterosexual writers
about how great America is.
That seems to be the epitome of what they
want.
They truly can't handle any other ideas, any
other identities, any other sort of content.
They are the very snowflakes they claim that
the left actually is catty.
Lover says Name one law that has been passed
that censors.
That's not the right version of censors that
censors the thing you are claiming.
If you were referring to limiting teachers
from discussing topics like gender, sexual
orientation, or the making up of multiple
pronouns with children in 1ar second or third
grade, I would ask, How are you okay with
it?
I don't even know what this person is asking.
I just.
It's it's clear they don't like the left wing
perspective and they favor the don't say gay
bill.
But what I really need people to understand
is when they talk about parents rights and
being heard at school board meetings and blah,
blah, blah, all this different stuff.
This is the type of commentary they want to
hear at school board meetings.
They want to turn the school board meeting
into a veritable circus sideshow with stuff
like this.
And that's exactly what they did during the
pandemic era with the masks and at other times.
And if they were to be in control, that's
who would be in charge.
That should scare every single one of us.
A Florida Sun says, say what you want about
his personality.
Him being DeSantis.
Florida has one of the best economies in the
U.S.
We're below average for crime, both violent
and property crime.
He doesn't govern with his personality.
He's not out to be a reality TV star.
He knows how to get the job done.
That is what should be important.
A beautiful story, but it is only a story.
As I told you before, Florida doesn't have
one of the best economies in the U.S. It's
right around 25th.
It's average.
You take any state in the country, there's
a 5050 shot that it has a better versus worse
economy than Florida.
Florida's economy is totally middle of the
road.
Florida's crime rate.
Totally middle of the road.
It's not particularly good.
It's not particularly bad.
Access to health care in Florida, very mediocre
infrastructure in Florida.
Similarly, middle of the road.
And so the story of this Florida success that
DeSantis is touring the country talking about,
if it's examined even at all, it immediately
becomes clearer.
Florida is right in the middle.
Not a particularly successful state, not a
particularly unsuccessful state.
And then the question becomes whether we think
that that record is worthy of a presidential
candidate.
Republicans will have to answer that question
first.
They can decide, are we impressed by the Florida
record of DeSantis?
Enough to make him the nominee instead of
Donald Trump?
Non-quarterback wrote in and said, Let me
ask a question.
Should business owners be able to choose whether
or not they require masks but not be completely
controlled by the state if they don't wish
to bake a cake for a gay wedding?
Well, it's a beautiful analogy, except that
it is completely nonsensical.
When in the United States we talked about
protected classes of people.
In some states, LGBT identity, gender identity,
sexual orientation is a protected class.
If indeed LGBT is a protected class, then
discriminating against someone on that basis
would be against the law.
Whereas saying we have a policy here where
you've got to wear shoes or you've got to
wear a mask or whatever would be a completely
different category.
Now, I'm not an unreasonable person.
If what individuals are saying is there should
be no protected classes and everybody should
be allowed to do whatever they want and say,
we don't want black people in this store.
We don't allow Jewish customers here
or wh